about now to our breaking news story out
of Russia where at least six people have
been killed at a school shooting in the
Russian city of izzefs well Mohammed Val
joins us now from Moscow Mohammed what
more do we know
uh yes what we know from the Russian
sources official sources is that six
people were killed one of them is the
god of the school but also we know that
the shooter killed himself in the
operation the identity of this shooter
hasn't yet been established and lots of
investigation and you know police and
authorities at the place and families of
the victims also this is a school in the
town of ijevsco the city of ijevsk in
the Republic of
this is a Russian federal republic and
it is about a 1 000 kilometers east of
Moscow not nothing is known about the
motivations behind this shooting and
Russia hasn't been seeing much of these
incidents but they happen I'm told so
there will be time before we we know the
details and why this man committed to
this act as you say it's not the first
school shooting in Russia in recent
times it does cause deep shock and
concern across Society there doesn't it
of course any shooting at the school is
a is a is a cause of deep concern for
authorities and for families and for the
nation in general we have seen that in
the US in many other countries but
Russians here are saying that this is
not a frequent incident in Russia and
most of the time I mean it's difficult
to establish the motives behind it this
man has killed himself nobody knows
whether he really realized what he
wanted what why did he do this you know
was his purpose just to kill five or six
children and a god of the school so it's
it's very difficult to link it also to a
any terrorism motivation or anything
else so it's very early it's very early
to know the causes okay for now Muhammad
Vali in Moscow thank you